an academic conference you know donuts
those of you who are from boston know
there's a dunkin donut on every corner
at berkeley that's a
that's a hard find
okay so i'm extremely happy that to
introduce sandhill muliana that is going
to speak today from the university of
chicago and he's an amazing researcher
who's done
you know
enabled us to understand a lot of the
choices that are made in
machine learning and what's the problem
with them
uh
in understanding sort of complex
behavior
uh of humans and social policy and
especially in medicine and in other
areas and uh he's a macarthur fellow and
he
has been recognized all over the world
for his pioneering work and i met him
during the privacy
uh i think
program at um simon's the first year
that i was here it was actually
wrong at the root workshop where you
explain to us why what we were doing was
wrong at the root
uh but uh
thank you so much for coming and i'm
really looking forward to your talk
thank you very much uh today i'm going
to talk about um
a topic that
is at its heart theoretical but
i'm only going to be presenting
something empirical and the reason for
that is that i hope to invite all of you
into seeing that in this empirical work
that's been ongoing there is a big
conceptual hole
and i'm going to try and use the data
and the results in this one particular
study to highlight an unmodeled aspect
and that unmodeled aspect is that the
intersection between algorithms and
people and in particular as i say here
fragile algorithms but fallible people
the place where we've seen that in the
place where we've seen that intersection
the most is on issues of algorithmic
bias
which is very familiar i think to most
of you by now so i'm not going to talk
about that issue today it's obviously
very important but exactly because that
particular issue is so well trodden
modeled i want to cast a different net a
bigger net at the intersection between
people and algorithm so let me start
with a very concrete problem imagine
you're a doctor in an emergency room and
a patient comes in
clutching their chest complaining of
chest pain perhaps shortness of breath
perhaps
trouble breathing nausea
now
immediately one thought that will come
to mind for you
is is the person having a heart attack
now
there are
for most of you you might think oh are
they having a heart attack well that's
either they're gonna die or not or if
they've had one they've had one and
they've survived but in fact it's not as
simple as that
even if somebody's had a heart attack
the nausea the chest pain and it passes
it's very important to figure out did
they just have a heart attack
and the reason for that is that after a
heart attack there's scar tissue left
behind and if that's not dealt with
there are some long term consequences
the long-term consequences are pretty
severe including another heart attack
and higher rates of mortality the reason
it matters to find out is because we now
can do something about it if you realize
this person in front of you just had a
heart attack there is treatment called
stenting which can go in and in fact
deal with this problem and in randomized
control trials you see
big reductions in mortality and other
consequences so person comes in and what
you have to decide is oh my goodness am
i going to treat them for a possible
heart attack well the benefits of the
treatment depending on depend on whether
they had such a blockage
and so what you really need in this
problem to go back to this original
patient is you need to be able to say i
see this patient what i love to do
is to have a test to figure out if
they're having a heart attack so this is
what the emergency room doctor
ultimately is facing
now there are some cheap tests
you know you can just do an ekg you can
do blood work but unfortunately those
cheap tests uh which you can do pretty
much on everybody are not that
conclusive
so this brings us to the heart of the
decision i want to talk about today the
doctor faced with this patient must
decide whether to do one of these better
tests
that are also incredibly expensive when
i say expensive i don't just mean
dollars i also mean they're very very
invasive and have some problems some
health problems of themselves that they
could raise
so how should the physician go about
deciding whom to test and whether it's
worth testing so i'll put up a very
simple framework here that is well
simple it's too complicated but we'll
bring it back to simplicity for a second
you know face
faced with the patient
the physician has to make this testing
decision the test produces a test result
which then leads to this stenting
decision
and if there's a blockage there'll be a
positive test result
so who to test well remember notice from
this that the benefits of the test
depends on whether a blockage is found
so ideally what you'd like to test is
those with high enough prior probability
of having a heart attack that's the
ultimate rule in this very complicated
situation you have to form a prior
belief given everything i see is this
person high risk and if they're high
enough risk
test them notice in this case the
treatment decision follows pretty
mechanically if the test is positive
treat them if not don't don't treat them
so let's simplify this a little bit
notice there's a pretty canonical kind
of graphical model we can set up here
given a patient the physician
forms a prediction
and on the basis of that prediction they
must they will test or not test
it should be very familiar to you and we
call these problems sort of prediction
policy problems let me just run you
through how this type of situation
is a kind of decision that appears in
the world and is distinct from another
kind of decision
so let me put this on the left patient
predict the test
test produces a result
here predictions record but of course a
lot of times for example when you're
making treatment decisions
causality is core
that is the doctor must decide will this
treatment have an effect
i point this out because i think very
often when thinking about human decision
making
there's a focus on causal
and causation and experiments in fact
all of medicine appears to be about the
machinery of experiments
but in fact as you see in this example
we have one experiment that tells us the
benefits of stenting
and then we leave in the doctor's hands
millions of decisions
that are essentially predictions
even though both are statistical
activities that need to take place
weirdly not weirdly but the right hand
side has been dealt with a lot the
left-hand side has been left to human
judgment largely speaking
and so
what i want to talk about a little bit
today i'll skip this bit here
is that many many problems share this
structure so i hope that while we talk
about the testing decision today you can
immediately see this applies to many
things i'll just give you an example in
the criminal justice system judges must
predict whether a defendant poses a
particular risk and release them on that
basis
in
the educational system
the person making admissions decisions
must predict the person's eventual
performance and admit
in hiring you must predict skill
in lending you must predict financial
health we can kind of keep going like
this all these problems have this shared
structure
and in the shared structure
the prediction structure kind of lends
them very naturally to say oh this looks
like a machine learning problem in fact
i haven't said it but it was probably
pretty obvious to all of you we're
taking characteristics and predicting
something there you go
and so
what i want to tell you today is that
i'm going to apply what is a kind of
obvious machine learning to this problem
but what i hope to do in the application
is reveal to you that this is not an
obvious application of machine learning
that it should not be the field is a
little bit heading in that direction but
it shouldn't be heading in that
direction
that there is structure underneath these
models that should be better modeled and
that that better modeling will i think
eventually lead us to better
applications
so let me start with the mechanical
approach the mechanical approach would
be say oh so you're telling me
you just need to predict whether the
person has a blockage let me just go
ahead and do that let me get a bunch of
data
and let me build a risk predictor
for a patient as to whether they have a
blockage and then i'll just compare the
risk predictor to the doctor and i'll
just see who does better okay so let's
just run through that a little bit
so
first is to build then to compare and in
the compare part it's going to look like
the usual horse race oh does the
algorithm beat the doctor okay so let's
start with the building part
so for the building part
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
take a bunch of data we have in a large
health system
and i'm going to take everything that we
know
up to this point which is i keep hitting
the wrong button so this is the
emergency room visit and this is the
anchor point i'm going to take
everything that's known up to that point
and just throw it into a prediction and
the outcome i'm going to predict is the
outcome of the test did this person have
a blockage okay that's going to produce
a pretty straightforward predictor using
a large set of people
great
i'm going to
pause here to make one
very very very
nitpicking point
but it is important because without this
point
some
other issue is going to be lost so let
me make this nitpicking point what
exactly do i use at the time of the
visit
so there's a couple of data that we have
available
for example the demographics the
diagnosed conditions all of that that's
one set of data there's another set of
data we have which is like what was the
patient's chief complaint what did they
say to the triage nurse
now
we're going to use
only
i won't you guys should start making
bets of whether by the end of this talk
i will figure out which one is the
which button i'm not sure myself okay so
we're not going to use this data
the narrative story etc the reason we're
not going to use that is because this
data is not reliably available what do i
mean by reliably available if you go
into the data frame
the way chief complaint and especially
the narrative stories are recorded
they're recorded after the patient
encounter
which means that the doctor kind of
knows what's already happened when they
go to write down what the patients said
so there's a ton of information leakage
here
okay this is going to be important in
our story later but we're not going to
use any of this information and we're
just going to use everything we knew
about the patient before they walked
into the emergency room
all right so just build a simple
algorithm using these data i'm going to
show you all the results in the holdout
set
and
what would we do next well we should
just ask the algorithm i just built what
is its auc
relative to the auc of the
doctor
but there's a problem
there is no auc of the doctor
algorithms make predictions
doctors don't make predictions
doctors make decisions
their predictions are implicit in their
decisions
the simple act that we're used to in
running horse races between two
algorithms becomes nearly impossible in
every one of these situations we can't
simply compare predictions we only have
their decisions
so as a first pass
we have to compare the consequences of
the predictions and compare decisions
and form counter factuals
okay so that's the first barrier in this
kind of problem so let's think about
that let's just take my prediction
discretize it at some point let's not
worry about the detail what i'll do is
i'll take the continuous prediction of
blockage and put a threshold and that'll
give the algorithm a suggestion whether
to send the patient home or to test and
the physician has a decision whether
it's send home or test of course when
they agree there's no
gain the net gain is zero for both so we
need to look at the off-diagonal cells
and ask how well
do they do how what are the outcomes
here
if the algorithm is right
and uh it sends home a patient who the
doctor tests then there will be test
costs saved
if the algorithm is right and
it tests the patient the physician would
have sent home there's some bad health
outcomes that would have been gained
does that make sense to everybody so
basically the two gains are very
different if the algorithm is right here
there's dollar saved if the algorithm is
right here there's lives saved so to
speak
okay
so now comes the question well how would
we actually go about calculating these
counterfactuals
well it's pretty easy if the algorithm
says send somebody home and the doctor
tested them
well let's actually look at what
happened to those tests we can actually
see how many of those tests came back
positive and the algorithm sent them
home so we'd see what the negative costs
are so let's have a look at this and
with our stuff with our algorithm on the
x-axis i put the decile of predicted
risk
on the y-axis i put the actual yield
of the tested sample
this population is the lowest decile the
algorithm predicts there's no reason to
test these people and in fact they have
very very low yield rates
using well-established calcul
cost-benefit calculations we can decide
the threshold at which we want to draw
it but you can already see
the low the low deciles have almost no
positive rates
if you convert all this using
cost-benefit calculations you get
something that looks like this x-axis
percentile of patient y-axis cost per
life year this is probably the most
embarrassing thing that
economists do is to put
dollars on human life
but nevertheless there we are and you'll
see that at the lowest decile of
patients it is well above any cost
effectiveness threshold that anybody
abuses above about a magnitude of order
of magnitude above it simply is not at
all sensible to tests in these lowest
quintiles in fact
you could cut 62.4 percent of all tests
um in fact you go further you could just
drop 25 and have no noticeable effect on
positive yields they're just not these
people contribute to almost nothing
so if i were to pause here and i want
you to consider this
one thing we've seen already here is
that at a minimum the algorithm is
identifying a set of patients for whom
we are spending lots of dollars and
remember these tests aren't neutral
we're actually sitting tubes into them
categorizing them to look for stuff
where there is just nothing there
so in that sense
we look like we have some gains but this
calculation only is one side we've shown
that we can cut wasteful tests
but what about the other side of this
equation
how do we go about calculating these
counterfactuals well let's go back to
our graph i said look this is what
happens to the low predicted risk let's
look what happens to the high predicted
risk in the high predicted risk
about 52 percent
find something that's a very high rate
and you should definitely be testing
those people
except
57 of them go untested
that would almost lead you to say holy
cow what is going on
but i'm pulling the wool over your eyes
for a second let's just look at this
graph
what could possibly be on the y-axis
it's
the yield rate amongst the tested
and then i'm saying
it's a 52 yield amongst the tested 57
are untested why don't we test them
but how do we know that the 57 that are
untested or anything like we don't have
actual labels for these people it's just
a leap of faith
and in that sense we could say there's
huge gains but not obviously we don't
know what the test actually would have
resulted in
if we had tested them
and that's important
because this problem i'm about to
describe and seeing in this figure is
generic
the labels are missing here for this
population it's not missing at random
it's missing exactly because of a choice
the physician made
the exact choice that we would like to
say the algorithm can do better than
so
as a result this problem what happens in
this cell the lack of a label
is a recurring theme that happens in
many decision tasks that is the data is
the result of past choices and that is
the deep sense in which as an empirical
matter comparing humans to machine this
machines
poses a problem the decision makers
choices influence what data we see which
perversely makes it harder to evaluate
alternative decision rules it's almost
like the physician is deleting the data
needed for us to overwrite what they
would do
but the important thing here is that we
must not be naive in how we go about
making this comparison so let me just
give you an almost comical comparison of
people and machines i hope you know
which one is a person which one's a
machine
the
algorithm has access to more instances
and that is one thing worth keeping in
mind right now every single patient who
walks into this health system is
available to the algorithm any given
doctor
might have seen
10 000
but and this is the key
human also has an advantage
and if we're going to make this
comparison and understand what happens
in that cell for which we don't have
data we have to recognize that the
doctor sees more about each instance if
this were a data frame
the algorithm has more rows
the human decision maker has many more
columns many of which never appear in
our data set
and to make fair comparisons we have to
do something about the fact that the
columns are missing and the labels are
missing for those columns so the
patients are not the same
in that untested cell and this is why i
went through such
pointless detail to point out to you
even with some of the data we have we
have to leave it out
so to make this very stark we have no
idea if the patient walked in and was
looking sick or not looking sick we
don't have a photo of what they were
what their skin pallor was
there's a lot missing in this data
as an extreme example let me just tell
you one thing that's missing for almost
every data set like this that you'll
ever see in this healthcare case
the
ekg
which is
the electrocardioid readout of the heart
people say oh i've got claims data i've
got health records but the ekg is rarely
in the health records in fact when we
went and got the ekgs and built a new
algorithm to predict blockage using the
ekgs which was not in our original
algorithm
what you find is on the x-axis is the
original predictor on the y-axis is the
risk predictor using the ekg
notice what the distribution looks like
everyone's risk goes down
on app not everyone but on average risk
goes down that's because people look
less risky when we add the ekg data why
is that because many of the untested
people
in fact had good looking ekgs and when
you add that in and so this is
systematically telling you of course
physicians know something that the
algorithm does not know
okay
and so when i said must not be naive in
this process we need a way of accounting
for the fact that the physicians have
private information that the doc that
the algorithm doesn't have
so
we do have a way of solving this i will
go through this
fairly quickly because to get to the
major points but
let me talk about let's go back to the
reason we tested in the first place
if you remember
if you
don't treat a heart attack
that did happen
that has these long-term consequences
but that has some the untested in our
sample are also the untreated
but as a result if predicted the
high-risk people are in fact truly
low-risk the physician knew what they
were doing
then what should happen to them over
time is that they should have low or no
complications
if the predicted high-risk patients are
in fact high risk because the physician
screwed up
looking over time we should find that in
fact they went on to have heart attacks
at high rates
but we can do this we can follow this
population over time after they're sent
home and measure what actually happened
to them and that's what i'm going to
show you here on the x-axis is again the
same predicted risk on the y-axis now is
measures of heart attack or death
and what you in fact find is that the
very high-risk people who were untested
and sent home go on to have
future heart attacks and death at very
high rates in fact the clinical
thresholds i'll go through this the
clinical threshold for testing someone
is right around here
which suggests testing everybody in the
top quintile would be incredibly cost
effective they're having death and heart
attacks that raised about twice the
levels at which you would expect to have
just said that we should test them
so what this tells you is that in fact
it's not just that the doctor is testing
too many people
but the people in the highest risk are
in fact being sent home
when they should not be being sent home
and they are dying at higher rates
so if you go back to this
cartoon
is said the doctor sees
more about each instance and the
algorithm sees more instances what we
have is a situation where we have an
analytical advantage by the algorithm it
is finding signal in these data that the
doctor is missing which suggests that
humans are fallible
but i want to go back and just point out
the doctor also has a contextual
advantage which is they see all these
things by these other patients that
contextual advantage is normally what we
think of as the fragility of algorithms
it's what leads to things like
distribution shift why when you move
from one context to another the
algorithm doesn't do nearly as well
so given these striking results we have
right now what i would like to ask is
the question what should we do with them
let me just
talk about this
we have some other evidence in the paper
which i won't go through
it suggests that there is some potential
for some very large gains where we could
change not just the costs in the health
care system but actually dramatically
improve the health of the people walking
in
which seems like it's very practically
useful
but it's almost useful because all it's
really telling us is that the algorithm
is finding some signal that the doctor
has left on the table
how do we actually go about deploying it
given the human advantage
and given that there's a bunch of stuff
not in the data and we have problems of
distribution shift
it's very hard to believe that
automation is the efficient solution
despite these results
so
yes we know that in this particular
narrow case we might think the algorithm
beats the human but you might almost say
great then we want to combine them and
what we'd really like is decision aids
and this is where i want to pause there
are many problems that are working their
way towards this point where
there is
a problem that looks like this there's
some data there's some compelling
evidence using natural experiments using
stuff like we've been describing that
says yes the algorithm appears to find
signal and the reason for that is
because humans are pretty biased at
extracting statistical information from
data sets it's just they're not great at
it
and that point you say well we must
build decision aids but what does it
mean to build a decision aid
how do we even model this problem
we sort of have to model how humans
react to advice
is it obvious that if you give a
decision aid that the doctor is going to
respond in the cases
where the aid knows something and the
doctor doesn't what if they only respond
in the case where the algorithm tells
them something that they already believe
but not in the case where it doesn't
believe you could be making matters
worse
it's hard to know how you build a
decision aid without even modeling the
human being and i don't know of many and
this is the invitation i'd like to
extend to you is to start to pull at
this thread and show you we just don't
have ways of thinking about this problem
we have theories like information design
and perhaps that's the right way of
thinking about it but here's the one
achilles heel of information design
those type of models
they presume a rational agent
but we wouldn't be in this mess
if the agent was perfect at extracting
the information
from the data
so that's one puzzle let me go a little
further
even in thinking of it as a decision aid
are we thinking too narrowly
to do this let's go back and say
well so far we've tried things like is
the algorithm better than the human can
we combine them but there are other
operators
what if we had the algorithm not predict
blockage but actually predict what the
physician will do
could the algorithm be a way of
diagnosing not heart attack but
diagnosing the error in physician
decision making
in principle we could do that because we
could take the cases and predict
physician judgment and ask
in which cases does that contrast with
predicted risk and what happens in those
cases
let me just give you an example of one
thing that happens there just so you get
a flavor of what those results look like
the i'm going to build such an algorithm
and the way i'm going to build this
algorithm is predict physician decision
making
using a risk predictor
but instead of using the best risk
predictor and seeing whether physicians
respond to that i'm going to build a set
of risk predictors and the way i'm going
to build a set of risk predictors is i'm
going to allow the risk predictors to
vary in complexity this is the simplest
risk predictor this is the most complex
risk predictor obviously as you keep
going in this direction there's
overfitting so on the top curve i'm
showing you what happens to risk how
well the risk predictor predicts risk
and you can see the overfitting that
happens as i get more and more complex
you can see there's a drop off in
performance so this is the overfitting
that happens so the best risk predictor
uses about 224 variables to predict risk
the second curve shows you what which
risk predictor predicts physician
behavior the best and you'll notice
interestingly that's a much simpler risk
predictor in other words
the best predictor of how a physician is
going to choose
involves a model of risk that's
significantly simpler than the best
model of risk
physicians appear to be using a much
smaller set of information
to make their decisions than what the
algorithm would use
and in fact if you take their set of
information
and
these are the variables in the small
risk predictor and correlate it with
risk or correlate it with the test
decision physicians are doing a
remarkable job
at
putting weight on the variables roughly
the way the algorithm would have put
weight on the variables so
this part almost makes it seem like
they're boundedly rational they use a
simple set a small set but they use that
set pretty well with one noteworthy
exception
if the reason for the visit was chest
pain physicians weigh that much more
heavily in their testing decision than
any relationship with risk
and so what you tend to find here is
physicians ignore this long tail of
information
and they overweight salient
representative symptoms like chest pain
and we talk a little bit more about this
and part of what i want to just
highlight is that this hopefully helps
you see that the design space cannot
just be i give a decision aid because if
i just give a decision aid it means
there's a ton of other information
that the algorithm may have about where
the
decision maker is wrong that then could
also play into a role
and so it feels like there's some and
let me conclude on this bit
it feels like if we're going to make
progress in this area
what we need to understand is we need to
understand what is the design space
that
is at the intersection between these two
agents even something like decision age
is far too narrow even something so what
is all the information that could be
given given that there are two entities
that have some understanding of the
situation and how do we model the design
space of what goes back and forth and
this requires a model of people
a model of algorithms
and importantly a model of what this
interaction space looks like and that's
what i will leave open here and i hope
that this is a problem that some of you
get interested in because at least in
the empirical work you see this
appearing
in many many places and it is kind of
one of those unexplored areas that i
think
theory of the type you all do could be
incredibly valuable all right thank you
[Applause]
and are there any questions
thank you sending very interesting talk
um i had a question about uh
when you drew this square where you know
comparing the decisions of the
algorithms and so forth i'm curious so
how did you train your algorithm your
algorithm was presumably trained on data
of people tested right i mean so so this
is data that is not missing at random so
there is already bias going into your
algorithms
uh into the data that your algorithm has
access to to train itself nevertheless
there was enough signal to do better
than the
doctors who filtered the data is that
what happened there uh first of all 100
you have it exactly right this is
trained on just a tested set but what
you're implying is also something very
important which is if you
had a model of how the decision aid was
going to be used
it's hard to believe that the right
training would just be to train naively
on the testing set so i think an
understanding of what's going to happen
downstream should truly even have
implications of who you even train on
why are we treating this population the
same why aren't we changing the training
procedure i totally agree
any more questions
uh thanks for the fascinating talk uh so
i guess uh just
so
uh
i guess one way we know of improving
simple algorithms is to kind of
give them new examples which
we know that this algorithm is doing
badly on so i guess this is sort of the
idea behind boosting multiplicative
weights
uh so i guess
in
if we think of the human itself as the
algorithm we are trying to improve could
we kind of use some of these
examples that you found where
the human made a mistake like basically
all the features that the human was
ignoring
could we perhaps use those to design
kind of do some kind of curriculum
learning kind of create new
well show doctors
examples of patients where
they would perhaps have made the wrong
decision uh do you think there's hope of
doing something like that oh it's
awesome yeah no and i think that's
exactly the kind of thinking this area
needs because in some sense taking these
ideas like boosting and
stuff you've seen in pack learning and
say well let me just turn it back around
and view the human as this box that i
can then give examples to and you can
even think of finding not just instances
they've done well maybe you want to find
instances that look very similar pairs
of instances where they look similar one
which they get wrong there's just a lot
when you pull that thread and i think
that's exactly the kind of stuff this
thinking this area needs
okay thank you very much again
and also thank you for coming